well now on our top story and the fires
that have been burning across northern
and central Israel this past week we're
joined now by The Jerusalem Post
reporter Dan Eisenberg who is in
Jerusalem dan good morning what's the
latest on these fires morning Kimberly
they are at this point contained many
are still burning there have been over
200 throughout the country the most
serious of which was in Haifa a northern
port city where upwards of 80,000
residents have been evacuated with
literally dozens of homes destroyed by
the blaze okay and you've had the Prime
Minister come out and say that basically
this is terrorism arson terrorism so who
are they blaming for setting these fires
I think that a government and the police
as well as Shin Bet are being very
careful in terms of their investigation
and I've yet to make any particular
accusations beyond the fact that it is
it does appear to be terror related I
know that there are forensics teams
spread out throughout the country to
find out how these fires happen they are
questioning a number of suspects
although I don't know that there have
been arrests yet but the police are also
quick to caution that there are high
winds and dry weather that has helped
spread any any of the fighters that did
start so they're not yet accusing anyone
of doing this any groups in particular
but are certainly preparing to find out
exactly how this all happened and if you
look at the location and if it is
terrorism if it's politically motivated
if it is us and why would they have
chosen these specific places to start
these fires well it's pretty
far-reaching were they with the fires it
was in the north in the central part of
the country and over 200
fires set so I don't know if it was a
concerted effort certainly over the last
three days they had burned close to
2,000 acres of land mostly forests in
rural areas and then hiked but certainly
many homes
I I don't know what kind of coordinated
effort this is if it is in fact that but
the right-wing political parties will
have already said that this clearly is
terrorism while the more moderate
parties are holding and waiting to see
what the investigation concludes
although it is clear to everyone that
this is beyond a coincidence Israel ever
had fires on this scale before has it
ever dealt with anything like this yes
several years ago there was the most
deadly fire in decades was a Carmel and
there was thousands of acres destroyed
people killed and we had a tea from
multiple countries to help put it out
and a lot of lessons were learned from
that fire that had been applied for this
latest round and we have had help here
with Greece Croatia Russia and Turkey
who have sent airplanes to help us and
help the Israeli fire fighters other
people heeding the warnings are they
actually leaving their homes and if they
are where are they going yes and Haifa
as I mentioned close to over 80,000
people have been evacuated from their
homes and offices and they've been sent
to large public buildings other three
public buildings in the city where
people have been sent as well as a
football stadium and police have set up
a command center an information center
to direct the public and inform them of
any developments that are happening
fortunately there have been no deaths
there were a hundred people
approximately treated for smoke
inhalation but no serious injuries at
this point okay thank you so much Dan
Eisenbud a reporter there for The
Jerusalem Post thanks dad